in the previous video we understood the
triple s congruence condition
let's remove the s in between and
understand the sas condition for
congruency
as you would have already guessed sas
means side angle side
but there's something important we need
to know here
the angle must be included between the
two sides given
we will understand what included means
in a bit
first let's understand what the
condition tells us
it says that two triangles are congruent
if two sides and the included angle of
one triangle are respectively equal to
the two sides and the included angle of
the other triangle
let's move to a new page to understand
this
say we have to draw a triangle abc with
the following information provided to us
we have a b equal to 4 centimeters
bc equal to 5 centimeters
and angle abc equal to 40 degrees
so triangle abc will shape up this way
angle abc is 40 degrees
a b is 4 centimeters
and bc is 5 centimeters
note that the angle is included between
the two sides
and if we have triangle pqr with pq
equal to 4 centimeters and qr equal to 5
centimeters
an angle pqr equal to 40 degrees then
the triangle formed will be exactly like
triangle abc
angle pqr is 40 degrees
pq is 4 centimeters and qr is 5
centimeters
if we take this triangle over to this
one they will overlap exactly
that is why we can say that triangle abc
is congruent to triangle pqr
so remember its side included angle
and side
this should make you wonder
would double s a work when the angle is
not included between the sides
let's see
we have been given the following data
about these two triangles
look at the data of the first triangle
we have been given a b and ac
the included angle should have been
angle a not b
this is not an included angle and the
figure would look like this
angle abc is 40 degrees
a b is 4 and ac is 3.
you can see that the angle is not
included between the two sides
now let's look at the data of triangle
pqr
it can be drawn like this
angle pqr is 40 degrees
pq is 4 and pr is 3. guess what they
will be congruent if drawn like this
but here's the interesting part
there is another way in which triangle
pqr can be drawn
like this
pq is for
prs3 and angle pqr is 40 degrees
in this case it is not congruent to
triangle abc
which means that double sa may or may
not work